this is a production of cornell
university
all right thank you so much for that
generous introduction mark it's really
terrific to be able to give my exit
seminar in person
um if on zoom i have removed the mic
from my mouth just type in the chat and
we'll try and fix that for you real fast
um so i'd love to start my talk today by
sharing the motivation behind my
dissertation which was to identify ways
that we can further leverage the
currency of plant breeding that being
genetic variation
and then i'll introduce one of my first
projects that i took on at cornell which
was to use a causal variant
approach to identifying genetic
variation during the mutation case study
um that inspired largely the remainder
of my dissertation where i'll introduce
the topic of controlled recombination
and whether as breeders we might be
interested in manipulating recombination
to further leverage the power of
selection and plant breathing during the
meiosis case study
and then there are some things that you
only learn in retrospect and i'll
conclude on some lessons that i've
learned during my phd
so plant breeders rely on heritable
genetic diversity and variation for
trait improvement and two of the primary
sources of genetic variation are
recombination and mutation of genetic
material during meiosis
and the crossovers that occur during
meiosis generate the novel and favorable
allelic combinations that breeders can
select upon
however these crossovers are very
tightly regulated this is a scaled
illustration of a wheat chromosome and
um we expect to see one to two
crossovers per chromosome per meiosis
and then the distribution along the
chromosome we expect those one to two
crossovers to fall on the chromosome
arms away from the pericentromere and so
this limited frequency
and bias distribution
ultimately governs our response to
selection and genetic gains
another source of genetic variation are
mutations and in a population novel
mutations can continuously arise
and their effects can range from lethal
to beneficial
as breeders our ability to actually
detect and select on those mutations is
limited by genetic resolution via
recombination so hence this being a venn
diagram for breeders these two
independent processes can have
overlapping consequences
um
some additional points of overlap
between these two processes starting on
the left-hand side in those regions
where there's fewer crossovers
deleterious mutations can start to
accumulate over lots of generations in a
breeding program
and evolution as well as on the
right-hand side through population
improvement and
artificial selection the allele
frequencies of some deleterious
mutations can increase due to
hitchhiking through selection and
because they might be in linkage with
traits of interest and then we get these
repulsion linkages so
given
this tight relationship between
recombination mutation and genetic
resolution as well as at the beginning
of my phd in 2017 the recent release of
an annotated wheat reference genome i
sought to address two primary questions
during my dissertation using wheat as a
model
and the first being
how can geneticists improve the accuracy
of identifying targets for positional
cloning
this is the first project that i took on
in mark's lab and the results of it
largely inspired the remainder of my
dissertation and asking the question
should breeders seek to manipulate
recombination to further harness the
power of selection
with the advancement of gene editing
techniques this there are some pretty
exciting proof of principle studies in
which this has been achieved changing
that frequency or distribution and i
wanted to ask thinking um many years in
the future potentially for a breeding
program would we want to apply these
technologies
so with that let's jump into the
mutation case study
where we're thinking about a pretty
dramatic form of mutation structural
variation
so i want to start by
reviewing the process of causal variant
validation via positional cloning this
is a foundational approach to go beyond
mapping traits that can span broad
genomic regions to validating selectable
markers that can help drive genetic
gains
and this traditional roadmap has been
quite successful for diploid crops such
as rice
and it generally starts with
a qtl of interest in your population
pursuing
a fine mapping population where we can
narrow our region of interest exploring
that region of interest in the reference
genome looking for candidate genes
sequencing those candidate genes to look
for variation and then with your top
candidates actually pursuing functional
validation for example with a gene
edited knockout
um and like i mentioned this has been
quite successful for
diploid crops um and with the release of
a fully annotated reference genome and
the advancement of gene editing
techniques this has opened the door to
positional cloning opportunities in
wheat as well
so in the sorrels lab we've worked with
this by parental population w7984 by
opata for over a decade and consistently
we've observed a qtl that has strong
associations on chromosome 5a on the
long arm with grain weight variation
um
and in 2017 when we became
collaborators on the wheat coordinated
agricultural project which is a usda
grant and the goal was to identify genes
that can contribute to yield improvement
we thought that this would be a good qtl
to pursue for positional cloning in
collaboration with the grant
now
when i dive into that story today i want
you to keep in mind that polyploids have
a lot of genomic structural variation
and structural variation meaning you
could have insertions deletions
inversions translocations along your
chromosome they can be small they can be
large but in a polyploid
the other genomes can buffer those
effects and your phenotype can be pretty
muted if even
measurable to the breeder so wheat has
an a a b and a d genome and i'm going to
jump into the story now of how we tried
or i tried to positionally clone the qtl
on chromosome 5a on the long arm and i
was overpowered by a structural variant
and present some recommendations to the
field that i hope can help um reduce the
likelihood of mapping in the wrong
direction and
are more sensitive to these structural
variants that are common in polyploids
and so
um
in order to find map this qtl i took a
heterogeneous inbred family approach
and or abbreviated as a hif and the
advantage of a hiff is that you start
with a fairy in red line we had
recombinant and red lines available for
our bioparental
um we identified one that was
segregating for the flanking markers of
our qtl
through lots and lots of rounds of
inbreeding many of its progeny we had
you know thousands of recombination
events that had a chance of recombining
between our flanking markers or qtl
um this approach is nice because you
have more confidence than in associating
the phenotype with those recombination
events as you have a really homogeneous
background genome and this is
advantageous for a quantitative trait
like grain weight because of those
subtle variations in the phenotype
so here we're starting by just looking
at the positive and negative controls of
the fine mapping population
the opata alleles um all the way across
in purple of that chromosome arm portion
of 5al where we had fine mapped our qt
or had started our qtl mapping process
um so the positive control is purple
oppada it's associated with a greater
grain weight on the right hand side um
of the graph and then the w7984 alleles
and teal
are associated with our negative control
as they have the lesser grain weight
and we
could then zoom out and look at all the
different recombination events that we
resolved in our fine mapping population
and um through a process of elimination
we can start to associate the positive
opa alleles with a greater grain weight
and then genomic regions that have the
w7984 teal alleles and a lesser grain
weight um we validated this with t-tests
as well and narrowed our qtl to a 10
megabase pair region blanking 37 genes
now i knew that i would eventually want
to look at the transcriptome for our
candidate gene so i also looked at the
phenotypes as the grain developed after
anthesis and narrowed the um
first phenotypic difference was detected
at 10 days post-enthesis which gave us
confidence that this trait was expressed
early if it was
controlled by the transcriptome was
expressed earlier in grain development
however
around the same time that we were
pursuing the fine mapping population and
identifying our transcriptome study a
publication came out where the authors
worked with the same biparental and one
of the most relevant findings from their
study was that um
the short arm of chromosome 5a of the
w7984 parent was missing
so what this suggested is that the
population was segregating for either
the presence of the short arm of the
alpata parent or an absence of a short
arm
and you know we're working with the same
population looking at the same
chromosome we didn't notice any
significant morphological variation or
infertility which is characteristic of a
missing chromosome arm
um but nonetheless this really prompted
our caught our attention and prompted us
to investigate what was going on with
the short arm in our population
so
i began by just running some
presence absence markers on our fine
mapping population and generally
more individuals had the short arm than
had it missing just based on these
markers
um but when we subset our population
based on which allele was present at the
qtl we saw a really skewed distribution
um
the presence of the short arm was in
tight linkage with the oppada allele at
the qtl and the presence of or the
absence of the short arm excuse me was
in really tight linkage the w7984
allele at the qtl
we can also look at this from the
phenotypic distribution perspective so
on the y-axis here is the 1000 grain
weight distribution and on the x-axis of
just subset based on the absence of the
short arm and presence of the short arm
and the colors are the opada allele
which we have been associating with that
greater grain weight
until this point in our study and then
the w7984 alleles associated with the
lesser grain weight
so i just want to call your attention
mainly to the few individuals that did
break ld on the right hand or sorry on
the left hand side for those couple
individuals that are missing the short
arm but have the opa alleles in purple
those individuals have some of the lower
end of the grain weight of all the
individuals that had the opa allele
the in on the right hand side that red
star next to the one individual that has
the short arm but was missing the w79
but has the w784 allele at the qtl has
the greatest grain weight of all the
w7984
alleles so
ultimately all this suggests is the
presence and absence of the short arm
could be contributing to our difference
in grain weight
um despite our best efforts to develop a
very homogeneous background genome um
the
uh
qtl or the structural variant we're not
sure which one is driving the difference
in green weight
so this is where the transcriptome
really came in handy um i looked at a
range of different haplotypes and time
points and i'm just going to touch on a
couple that are most important to the
study today
um i'll present the positive control
which was a haplotype linkage between
the presence of the short arm and the
positive variant of the qtl and the
absence of the short arm and the
negative variant of the qtl
and
um we looked at the transcript of
genome-wide but i'm just going to show
you chromosome 5a because we were
successful in that regard of a fine
mapping population we did only see
differential expression on our
chromosome of interest
um so chromosome 5a is on the x-axis and
then differential expression is on the
y-axis so anything above that yellow
line which is our threshold for
significance means the positive and
negative control for a given gene had a
significant difference in expression
and the majority of the differential
expression falls on that short arm
that's actually due to no expression at
all from our negative control so that
validated that it was indeed missing in
our population
and the next
area i want to draw your attention to is
highlighted in red that's the 10 mega
base pair region of the qtl that i had
find mapped
and i did detect expression for those
genes from the positive and the negative
control but there was no significant
difference in their expression
so
this certainly made us pause and
consider the numerous years that we had
invested in this project and
you know driving towards this qtl in
this region it made me think did we get
the wrong time point for expression or
maybe this is not driven by the
transcriptome something's happening
post-transcriptome or post-translational
modifications
um so because we had done a full rna-seq
experiment i was able to look at the
coding sequence
and we
ultimately did not identify any
significant difference in the coding
sequence variation either
so what this ultimately starts to
suggest to us is that the
difference in grain weight was likely
driven by this chromosome structural
variation buffered by the other genomes
and the qtl was likely presenting as
an artifact of very strong linkage with
the
present absence of the short arm
ultimately this study presents a pretty
important point of how do we detect
chromosome structural variation in
polyploids
and i
you know i was working on
this project the w7984 by opata
populations are some of the most widely
cited mapping populations up until we
got our reference genome in 2017
and so aside from the very subtle
phenotypic variation
associated with the whole chromosome arm
deletion something that i wondered was
why did it take so long for the wider
wheat community to identify this
structural variant in a popular
population and i think i can explain
that a little bit with a timeline of
events
um up until 2011 the population had only
been genotyped with ssr and dart markers
so those are scored on a presence
absence basis and wouldn't have
necessarily alerted us to
anything different from a structural
variation presence absence
um in 2012 a gbs genetic map was
developed but again working with the
genetic map it might not have alerted us
to the fact that all the markers were
mapping to the long arm
it was really in 2017 with the release
of the reference genome that i think set
us up to identify this structural
variant and it also is what allowed for
the wheat cap project to move forward
and
giving positional cloning projects to
grad students
um
when i was working on developing a lot
of the fine mapping markers for this
project in early 2018 that's when i
first started to notice that i was
having trouble
um
identifying site-specific polymorphisms
on the short arm but it as our qtl was
mapping to the long arm it wasn't my
primary concern
it was really in 2019 for goodyear's
gonzales at all's group um with the
conjunction of access to a um
general physical map as well as the
dense gbs mapping that identified the
structural variant
and i just want to stress that
you know we generally think of dramatic
structural variations as associated with
a pretty dramatic phenotype or changes
in the fertility of the plant but in a
polyploid it's important to keep in mind
that the other genomes can buffer that
effect and you know across different lab
groups years research projects and
environments
a structural variant as dramatic as a
whole chromosome are missing went to
kind of flew under the radar for us
these are some other recent publications
highlighted here that um have with the
access to a reference genome and now
more of a pan genome approach and wheat
have underscored the structural
diversity of wheat and how important it
is to be mindful of structural variation
when you're taking a causal variant
approach to breeding
and so i've shared with you today my
experience with positional cloning and a
polyploid and how taking that
traditional roadmap to positional
cloning that i explained at the top
overlooked some unique hurdles to
polyploids and i think that if grad
students or research project groups are
going to continue to invest in
positional cloning projects for
polyploids there are some updates that
we should make to that roadmap and
i'm going to make some recommendations
that i hope could be implemented in the
near future
that would reduce the likelihood of
mapping in the wrong direction
and all of those recommendations can be
found in my paper um there i also
created a github repository that is
structured like a learning resource not
only is it our
full reproducibility of the paper and
the supplementary material it's very
easily digestible no matter your
experience with coding and i hope can
help others who i know will encounter
structural variants in their polyploids
with their own experimental design and
overcoming those roadblocks
but i do want to highlight a couple of
recommendations most relevant to what i
talked about today
the first would be to move from a snip
to a haplotype based approach to
identify genetic diversity i think we
all know that a snip can be in
association with your trait of interest
but that snip itself is probably not
causal and in a fine mapping context um
that can lead to trusting snips that are
in linkage across really broad swaths of
the genome in our case in linkage across
an entire centromere
ultimately this can lead to mapping in
the wrong direction
which happened in our case
using a haplotype based approach not
only does that give you more confidence
when actually identifying your target
for positional cloning because you're
going beyond a biparental to validate
that qtl
you also have
more awareness of your general diversity
across the genome whether that
structural variance on your own
chromosome or outside or sorry in the
background genome that you might want to
be mindful of during your find mapping
population development
and then the next recommendation would
be to use the transcriptome to narrow
your list of candidate genes
if i had followed that traditional
roadmap to positional cloning the
general recommendations are to just
continue to inbreed and look for
recombination events that further narrow
your list of candidate genes
narrow it down to just a few so that you
can run rtq pcr
um
we would have if we had done that we
would have just kept mapping in the
wrong direction and it was really
running a whole transcript seeing the
whole genome and looking at the
transcriptome that alerted us to that
structural variant and i don't think
everyone's going to be so lucky to have
a publication come out at the same time
you're working on a project that
highlights there's a structural variant
you should look for so i think one way
to do that it would be to use the
transcriptome earlier on in a fine
mapping population
and
um with that we're going to move on to
the meiosis case study but i do want to
introduce it by sharing that the
mutation case study is really what
inspired the rest of my dissertation it
was experiencing firsthand that reliance
that we have on meiotic or combination
not only to
pursue a positional cloning project and
find mapping but just our general
awareness of diversity across the genome
and so that brings me to the subject of
controlled recombination
and controlled recombination is really
an umbrella term
that refers to a suite of tools that can
be used to modify crossover frequency
and or distribution
and um what i'm talking we're returning
to this scaled illustration of a
chromosome in wheat with its crossover
um patterns
when i'm talking about frequency i'm
referring to that one to two crossovers
that we expect to see per chromosome per
meiosis and distribution meaning that we
expect those one to two crossovers to
fall within the chromosome arms away
from the pericentromere
and there's a range of approaches that
have been developed for controlled
recombination um
some might take a more generalist
approach where you
could start by modifying the over
combination frequency this might involve
like a knockout of an anti-crossover
gene and generally we just see an
elevated increase in recombination where
we naturally see it fall along the
chromosome
it's a little trickier to change the
distribution because it's not exactly
what the chromosome wants to do but it
has been achieved and for example in
this paper by pilot at all 2017
they had pretty remarkably
saw 20-fold increased recombination in
the perry centromere in turnips
and then as opposed to the generalist
approach we could take a more
site-specific approach and this is
actually achieving recombination at
specific base pair intervals on your
chromosome
so i imagine you're thinking about
generalist or site specific there's a
range of applications you could have in
your research or breeding program
and i'd recommend you read my paper if
you want to learn more about those and
for the sake of today i want you to just
keep in mind that
controlled recombination is a novel
approach that may more efficiently
harness the power of selection for plant
breeding
now
as it's a normal approach there's a
range of questions out there still as we
go from going from the lab bench and
model species to crop species and a
breeder's field
and a couple of questions that i really
like to focus on in this area are where
in the genome should we target
recombination to actually see a benefit
in our breeding programs and by how much
do we have to increase for combination
to see a significant response in
selection
and
across
the literature
there have been only evaluations of
controlled recombination in a breeding
program at this point via simulations
and across these simulations they're
pretty optimistic
whether it's different controller
combination approaches crops
um traits they can predict upwards of
doubling genetic gains
and when i was deciding what question i
wanted to focus on in this research area
and reproducing the results of some of
these papers i realized that the
majority of them focus on using
estimated marker facts to identify where
would be an optimal recombination point
and ultimately that limits your analysis
to historical recombination so that
frequency of where we generally see
recombination occur it's going to
overlook lower recombining regions and
where there can be some of those
repulsion linkages that i had referenced
at the top of the talk related to where
mutations might fall
um and so that's pretty good target for
controlled recombination and i thought
what would happen if we could create a
simulation that shifts recombination
towards perry centromere would we be
able to unlock new variation largely
motivated by just trying to make our
simulation studies um most reflective of
what the technology might be able to
accomplish
5 10 15 years down the road for breeders
this actually raises a tricky question
then of how do you test and evaluate the
effect of recombination in regions of
the genome where we've rarely measured
it and
using like biological priors in your
simulation and i thought that
deleterious variants could present a
good signal for us so these are
mutations that tend to have a negative
effect on fitness and they can
contribute substantially to phenotypic
variation this could be something like
an early stop codon or a non-sonomous
coding variant
and they can occur at higher frequencies
and lower recombining regions where they
haven't been able to be purged from the
genome and through artificial selection
and population improvements sometimes
that can mean being fixed in repulsion
with traits of interest though we do
want
and so identified a data set in which i
could ask simulate and ask this question
of what would happen if we changed the
recombination distribution and
frequencies and kept track of the
deleterious variance
um i this data set came from dr
catherine jordan's 2018 paper and we're
able to get 26 diverse wheat cultivars
for which the they were had um
xm capture data as well as the
deleterious variant annotations and they
were constant the paper showed that they
were concentrated in the pericentromere
so the way that i kind of used this as
an input to the simulation was thinking
um if you just had snip data your
pericentromere on a genetic map it's
very scrunched together you have a lot
of markers falling within the same
center morgan interval potentially how
do you actually identify which of those
might want to you might want to use in
your simulation to inform qtl i largely
used these by just
being able to identify hey there's an
early stop codon in the perry centromere
that's a good biological prior to inform
our qtl um where we when we wanted to
pair qtl distribution in the pair
centromere was increasing or a
combination there
so i'll get into a little bit more how i
use that in the parameters now
starting with just wild type
recombination here's just a histogram of
the first chromosome of wheat as an
example for the snip count along that
chromosome
and we worked with about 1200 markers
per chromosome
and one morgan that's about one
crossover on these as we used only the
genetic map for these simulations
and i could simulate changing the
recombination frequency just by changing
the scale of the genetic map so in this
case it's twofold larger that
lends itself to about two times more
recombination um but it hasn't changed
the distribution it's still going to
prefer to increase or have more of a
combination on the chromosome arms as
opposed to the pericentromere
and we tested up to 20 times larger
genetic maps
and then you can also change the
recombination distribution
this was done just by changing
recombination the scale of the map in
certain regions of the chromosome so i
wanted to preferentially increase
recombination in the pericentromere it's
highlighted here in red under the wild
type map and then the yellow maps to
fold larger for more of a combination in
the perry centromere
and
i kind of referenced this with my
motivation for this simulation the qtl
were either selected randomly or based
on whether they had a deleterious
variant annotation and then this data
set that was concentrated in the red
region of the highlighted pericentromere
so getting into a little bit of our
expectations given these parameters and
inputs
um i'm going to refer to these map types
as the wild type map type in blue
where we never changed the recombination
or the genetic map um
the chromosome map type in gray just
meaning that we changed for combination
across the entire chromosome and the
pericentromar map type in yellow meaning
that we changed our combination just in
the pericentromere
and i expected that the chromosome map
type would do the best just because it's
the largest map and it has the most
opportunities for more recombination and
that the perry centromere map type
would perform really well when it was
paired with the deleterious variant
annotations because you're increasing
your combination where the majority of
your qtl are
so
let's see if this actually happened um
we're looking at the y-axis on the
y-axis here is genetic variation and
it's just graphing how genetic variation
uh depletes in our populations over 10
cycles of genomic selection for our
populations on the right left hand side
is the two-fold increased recombination
maps and on the right-hand side are the
20-fold increased recombination maps
our map types again are highlighted by
their colors with blue for the wild type
the yellow for the pericentrial map type
and the gray for the chromosome map type
and on the two-fold increased map type
um sorry i'll introduce that in
under increased recombination we
expected to see that um
a larger map would retain more genetic
variation over cycles of selection
compared to wild type recombination
i highlighted it in red on the 2x
increased map because that's not what we
saw around five or six cycles of genomic
selection i'm highlighting here it's
traditionally kind of our duration of a
breeding program
we didn't see any real significant
difference in the genetic variation
retained under increased recombination
however under 20-fold increased
recombination those larger map types did
hold on to more genetic variation
compared to wild-type
when we consider from the same
population and its response in with
genetic gain over 10 cycles of genomic
selection
under the two-fold increased map type we
you know we didn't see a significant
difference in genetic variation routines
so it's no surprise that they performed
pretty similarly
similarly with genetic gain
um but then the 20x increased map type
surprisingly the increased maps actually
have worse genetic gain predicted than
the wild type um even though they had
more genetic variants to be selecting
from
and it turns out that the larger genetic
maps have lower genomic prediction
accuracy compared to wild type because
under increased recombination that ld
decays faster between the markers and
the qtl
so through these simulations this trend
started to emerge that there was a
trade-off in the genetic variation
retained under increased recombination
and whether that actually would
translate to an increase in genetic gain
variation could be generated from
breaking up repulsion linkages which is
beneficial and what we were
i was intending to have happen in my
simulations
and then you could also have variation
retained because you had lower
prediction accuracy
so i'm just going to present a few more
simulation parameters that either i
thought would help me understand this
trade-off or actually did help us
understand this trade-off and what could
lead to greater genetic gains
under increased recombination
so the first being the qtl annotation um
and whether those were deleterious
variants are just randomly selected
it turns out that there's a lot of other
variables that need to be in place for
these to start to have a response and
selection they weren't as important as
they thought they would be
but when we do have those other
variables in place which i'll get to in
a moment it is about what you would
expect that if your qtr qtl are in the
region that you're increasing the
combination
those will do better
um something that did really make a big
impact was the qtl effect ratio so we
modeled different ratios of coupling or
repulsion between our qtl
um you know coupling between your qtl
meaning two qtl that are next to each
other and they are in linkage and they
both have the alleles that were of
interest to us we don't really want
recombination to happen there um it
would be not beneficial under a
repulsion scenario it's the opposite two
qtl that are in linkage one has the
allele that you want and one has the
allele that you don't want and you need
recombination to get um the beneficial
combination what i want to point out
here is that under coupling and random
scenarios we actually didn't see very
much of a penalty under increased
recombination generally performed
similar to wild type
but we only saw an increase in genetic
gain and a response when we have
repulsion
the relationship matrix refers to how we
estimated the marker effects and the
genome-wide relationship matrix is
standard practice it's this was not a
simulation it's all we would have access
to
um basically this is what
suffers from the ld decay between the
markers and the qtl under increased
recombination
the causal variant relationship matrix
was something unique that we could do
with a simulation because it's basically
just we knew the exact locations of our
qtl
and so we could feed those right into
the model and that's a proxy for perfect
ld or
maybe you got really good at positional
cloning and you knew the locations of
all your qtl
so let's see how these different
variables play together in a response to
genetic gain
we're going to consider just 20 times
increased recombination frequency
because we didn't see a significant
response under lower frequencies and
this is pretty similar to the literature
folks have found that you need a
dramatic increase in recombination to
see a response in these simulation
studies
um 200 qtl per chromosome so a
quantitative trait
with relatively high heritability
because we did not see a response to
selection under lower heritabilities
um and then i'll present also the qtl
effect ratios with different shapes on
the graph so the coupling are
represented with circles and the
repulsion scenarios are represented with
triangles
the genome-wide relationship matrix
results or first consider on the
left-hand side and then the causal
variant relationship matrix are on the
right-hand side and again this is the
genetic gain on the y-axis over the 10
cycles of genomic selection
so starting with the genome-wide
relationship matrix even under
20 times increased recombination with a
quantitative trait and high heritability
and all of your qtl and repulsion
it doesn't we didn't see necessarily
that both increased genetic maps
performed better than wild type the peri
centromere map type did better than wild
type but the chromosome map type i think
just gets too large to overcome that ld
decay
so we can consider then when we remove
ld
from the equation the causal variant
relationship matrix or sorry ld decay
from the equation um
after 10 cycles of genomic selection we
can see especially when the qtl are
under repulsion up to 15 greater genetic
gains with an increased map compared to
wild type recombination
so some observations that come from
these simulations are that increased
recombination is going to retain more
genetic variation
but at least in our data set there were
some pretty limited instances in which
this actually translated to greater
genetic gains
if you have a quantitative trait with
high heritability and really
well-defined qtl locations which
i'm not familiar of a trait like that in
wheat but if we pretend that that exists
in the future
having those in repulsion is going to be
those qtl and repulsion in your
population would be important and you
may need to go beyond six cycles of
genomic selection
so
this is probably a deal breaker for most
wheat breeders
but i do think controlled recombination
is a really interesting technology and
in theory has some pretty clear
applications to breeding programs
based on our data and simulation inputs
i'm not convinced that a generalist
approach over many cycles of selection
necessarily has the right home in wheat
across different simulation studies that
have been published there's been shown
to be a variation in the response to the
efficiency of controlled recombination
across different species so this could
be a species specific instance but
i have not seen results as pessimistic
as what i observed in weeks published
yet
um
i mentioned the different approaches
generalist versus site-specific
potentially a site-specific approach for
a qualitative trait could be a good
application of controlled recombination
and wheat
um and as the technology affordability
and feasibility aligns i hope that this
simulation and can inform future studies
as we consider what might be the right
applications of controlled recombination
to plant breeding
and with that i'm going to start to wrap
things up um with some of those that
yeah i only learned in retrospect during
my phd
um the first is to not get too attached
to your hypothesis
i think it's good to get comfortable
with null or negative results your goal
is to
learn from your data and be adaptable
and ask the next question and i think
the faster you learn this the better
scientist you'll be
i definitely was confronted with this
for the positional cloning project um
being on a large grant where the goal
was for all the groups to be cloning
genes that contribute to yield
components
you know eventually we had to recognize
that the structural variant was pretty
important to our project and pivot
so
that took you know letting go of an
original hypothesis
the next would be to test your
assumptions which is another way of
saying you should avoid assumptions if
you can
this came up for me a lot with the
controlled recombination simulations
just
based on
you know
population and quantitative genetic
theories that i like mueller's ratchet
or the hill robertson effect we would
think that increased recombination is
generally beneficial also a lot of the
publications out there for controlled
recombination really like tout its
benefits um so a lot of the simulation
for me and the parameters that i
presented were introduced as i started
to realize i wasn't seeing a response to
selection and i was making assumptions
about the population and uh what
actually uh
until we you know came down to the
variable that prediction accuracy in
lddk was
um regulating a lot of the response we
saw on selection
a third recommendation is as graduate
students to begin early in prioritizing
your data management and reproducibility
best practices i took this class in the
natural resources department and i would
recommend anyone take it it really
changed the way that i code and
collaborate and it'll save you when you
have a bug in your code for sure but i
think one of the greater benefits of it
too was the confidence to
publish null or negative results and be
able to validate those with really good
supplementary materials
for example i was able to do that with a
positional cloning study and it'll come
up again for me with the
control for combination simulations when
those get ready to publish
and then my last recommendation is to
take time to do an internship um this is
one of the reasons that i haven't been
on campus i took six months to work for
bear as a data scientist and it was one
of the best decisions i made in grad
school
it's a really good way to grow your
network and explore career opportunities
and if grad students or pis have
questions about how you can pull that
off you can always get in touch with me
and with that i have a lot of people i'd
like to thank
mark thank you for letting me be as
independent and trusting me as you have
and be able to explore the questions
that i was just most inspired by over
the last five years
to my committee margaret and adam your
advice and encouragement has been so
important and your flexibility i have
appreciated so much as i've navigated
the last five years
john luke working with you on this last
chapter has
made me grow as a scientist i think in
more ways than you know and working with
your lab
has really influenced the way that i
present scientific information and
communicate
i'm so thankful to synopsis for the
career-long relationships that we
started growing here at cornell
um thank you to the week cap for your
funding and putting me through grad
school
and to my family and friends and my
parents um i couldn't have done it
without you either thank you for always
being one phone call away
um
and with that thank you to all of you
for your attention i'd be happy to
answer any questions
[Applause]
all right we have a little time for
questions um
i want to recognize uh
la's parents i came all the way from
seattle to
to uh celebrate this event
um and so anybody that has questions so
i think moira is monitoring the chat
um
let us know
[Music]
travis what what's up well on your
simulations
um how did you develop the marker
estimates or the effect size estimates
that you used
to wear that control the combination
definitely okay so for people on zoom
the question was in the controller
combination simulations how did we
estimate the marker effects and the
effect sizes
so it was really important to us that um
across the simulations we had everything
begin the population at the beginning of
the simulation standardized everyone to
the same variance so that um was
standardized a variance of one the
estimated marker effects came with from
rr blup um
and we
the effect size the sign of the effects
was largely what we had to manipulate
for the different repulsion and coupling
scenarios to occur
so that
sorry i've told you this in a funny
order once we identified our coupling
and repulsion scenarios based on the qtl
effect sign then we standardized the
variance that changed the effect sizes
but i did also look at the data i can
it's in some supplementary data from
actually how different gta effect sizes
responded to selection
we saw some interesting situations where
for example like a very
um
some of the smaller effect sizes
deleterious variants would still come
along through selection so that's sort
of that hitchhiking effect of if it has
a small enough effect it will still
stick around under increased
recombination
does that answer your question yeah if
you put follow-up would be what uh what
proportion of variants came from the
centromere versus the arms
so for people on zoom the question is
what proportion of the variance came
from the centromere versus the arms and
i just don't look at that um
we had the markers we had worked with
1200 markers that were fairly evenly
distributed across the chromosome
so
i would say you know in the case with
the randomly distributed qtl
i would assume that there's i would have
to check but i'd assume there wasn't
very much difference between the arms
and this
centromere but under the deleterious
variant approach where we prioritized
qtl that we knew fell in those regions
there would be more variants explained
by the centromere
perry centromere okay thanks
ed go ahead
hi first off just wonderful
presentation and talk there
what i was wondering about when you knew
the causal variants did you have an a
priori estimate of the effect size of
the causal variant
that's one of the things that guillaume
ramstein when he's looked at that
getting some estimate there helped out
in prediction accuracy
that's a great question i did not
prioritize specifically certain qtl to
have
more of a
an effect size than others
um i let so i worked with alpha simar
for this and i just used the
distribution of effect sizes that it
gave so some would be larger smaller but
i think something i really learned from
this project was
uh with assuming having been someone who
has a lab background and then
transitioning later in throughout my
degree into more of a quantitative and
data science background
um
you can really quickly on a computer add
another variable and then that adds a
lot of work to your analysis this is a
great question and it's something i'd
want to explore but i think
i didn't
it didn't
fall into one of our simulation
parameters that we prioritized in our
first round of analysis thank you
that sounds good yeah
and yeah so i think you know guillaume's
kind of saw wait waiting did matter uh
if you could prioritize the causal
variants by the predicted uh
deleteriousness
that's a great suggestion i'll
definitely think about how we could
incorporate that thank you
mike very nice presentation
uh just a question on in terms of like
the 20x recombination scenario where
you're probably like first training the
model then you may even have changing in
phase between uh coupling and repulsion
as generations go on so with that then
rd you would have to retrain more often
for it
that is a great question okay so for
people on zoom the question was when you
increased like how did we retrain the
model in our simulations and
that is another you know point of um
hesitancy i have about my controlled
recombination for based on air
simulations i retrained it every
generation because i was not because of
our lowered prediction accuracy and i
was not seeing that response to
selection
some papers out there have actually
modeled changing it different how often
they trained the model
um
but we settled on training every
generation which is not ideal for a
breeding program
you would have
yes yeah so under increased
recombination retraining more often is
definitely um would be necessary and if
this was applied in the real world
yeah thank you
situation
okay so
looking back the question was at the
positional cloning project if
gene editing was available or controlled
or combination if controlled or
combination was available like from a
site-specific approach would i have used
it
um
well i did try to do that if we recall
if we think back to pre-pandemic times i
would go across the
transformation facility a lot trying to
optimize conditions for doing
transformations in wheat and i had this
lofty idea that i would validate my
positional cloning
project with doing it with far fewer and
fewer individuals and gene editing
um i have some hesitancies there just
because we encountered as you probably
recall how hard it was for our cultivars
to take in a
uh transformation facility so that's
another you know point of consideration
with controlled recombination something
that in the future we may have more
cultivars that work with tissue culture
but it was a limiting factor for me just
to begin
this project was just the parental we
were working with
didn't wasn't taking very well to tissue
culture so
in an ideal world if it was working i
think that would be a great experiment
to show that you could do positional
cloning much faster and with fewer
individuals
using controlled recombination and it
has been shown to work in yeast
some proof of principle studies like
that but
yeast is really different from plants
anything else
okay
let's thank uh
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu